- I wanna finish things up
with something particularly adorable
that I found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So you can never be exactly sure
what you'll discover
in the pages of a book,
and that's even more true
if that book is checked
out from a library.
Just look at some of the items
an Oakland, California
librarian has come across
in her 20 years on the job.
So, everything from little
notes to recipes and receipts.
Even a backstage concert pass.
(audience laughing)
Now she's helping reunite some readers
with their lost relics
with her Found in a Library Book project.
We have her on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to Sharon
watching on NBC Bay Area.
What's up, Sharon?
(audience clapping)
- Hi, how are you?
- Oh, you are so cute, by the way.
How did this get started?
- Oh, well, about 10 years ago
I was put in charge of
the library's website
and blogs were a big thing at that time.
So, I was trying to come up
with something that was fun
and would humanize the
library and library staff,
and I had my own little
collection of things I'd found.
So I reached out to library
staff around the system
and asked them to send me
anything they had found
and I turned that into a blog.
I got like so many cool things.
People leave all kinds of things in books.
There's bookmarks,
postcards, notes and letters,
kids drawings, a lot of
photos, a crochet hook even.
So, each one is like a
tiny anonymous glimpse
into somebody's life.
I really, I really love that.
So, last year we transitioned
to a different website
and I was able to put up the full archive.
And so, we have about 400 images up now,
and I have several hundred more
in a box under my desk waiting to go on.
- This is super cool.
So, you've found some really cool things
and also, you've been
able to reunite people
with their items, right?
- Yeah, so I personally
love the kids' drawings.
One of my favorites is a bookmark
with a drawing of a robot
labeled "Robot Daddy,"
and it has a speech bubble
that says "Calculating I love beer."
(Kelly laughing)
There's also a really lovely postcard
where a woman is writing to a man
and expressing that she's
wishing him best wishes,
even though he hasn't replied
to her previous 30 some messages.
- Oh.
- Yeah, we have actually
been able to reunite a woman
with some of her lost photos.
She saw them and reached out to us.
They were childhood
photos that had been lost
because she moved around a lot as a child.
She came and retrieved them.
She's pregnant with her own baby
and was so excited to have
these childhood photos
of hers to share.
- That is so cool.
Look what you did.
Even if just with a one person
that's such a remarkably cool thing.
Thank you so much, Sharon.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
- [Sharon] Thank you.
- And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and promoting reading
just like you, ma'am.
So, they're giving the nonprofit
Friends of the Oakland
Public Library $1,000.
(audience cheering)
- Oh, that is so amazing!
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- [Sharon] That's awesome.
- Thank you so much.
And a big thanks to Kenneth
Babyface Edmonds, y'all,
and Lawrence Zarian for
hanging out with us this hour.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.